vacunaciones a contrarreloj en lancha a
las orillas del río negro cerca de
manaos más de 400 dirigentes de ongs y
empresas lanzaron una iniciativa para
ayudar a las autoridades brasileñas a
acelerar la campaña de vacunación
especialmente entre la población más
vulnerable los ancianos de las
comunidades ribereñas cuyo acceso a los
centros de salud se antoja casi
imposible y que a lo largo de la
historia ha sido diezmada por la
aparición de enfermedades la pandemia de
kobe 19 no ha sido menos
damián está base es fundamental la
vacuna es la primera gran barrera que
tenemos ahora sabes todo el mundo tiene
que vacunarse la vacunación tiene que
ser masiva desgraciadamente no hay
muchas dosis para algunos privilegiados
como yo mira qué ironía la vida como el
movimiento denominado unidos por la
vacuna se dice a político y busca
asistir sobre todo a dinamizar las
tareas logísticas el gobierno de jair
bolsonaro blanco de críticas por su
gestión de la pandemia empezó a inocular
a sus 212 millones de habitantes hace
menos de un mes con el ambicioso
objetivo de terminar las vacunaciones
antes de fines de septiembre aunque los
expertos señalan que la campaña de
vacunación duraría cuatro años en brasil
unidos por la vacuna brindará apoyo
tanto al gobierno federal como a los 27
estados brasileños y a los más de 5000
municipios
tuvimos cierta resistencia incluso en
relación con los ancianos con el apoyo
de nuestros médicos que vinieron a
visitarnos también dando consejos sobre
los beneficios de esta vacuna
acabaron cediendo y entonces la
aceptación es muy buenas acabaron siendo
y aceite son está siendo muy tumbó a
brasil dispone hasta ahora de 12
millones de dosis aprobadas para su uso
de emergencia del laboratorio chino
sinovac y astrazéneca oxford hasta el
momento el epicentro de la pandemia en
américa latina' tan sólo ha inmunizado a
4 millones de brasileños